[موسيقى]
إنها 4:15 سنغني
أوبرا المعلم في سنغافورة بسبب صغر
سنّي إلى البالغين الذين أدوا
كمنتج لك ، يعتقدون أنها أصغر من
أن تؤدي مثل هذه الشخصية أم أنها
قادرة على أدائها بشكل جيد أم أنها  مجرد
القيام بذلك من أجل المتعة
[موسيقى]
أوبرا تشري هي شكل فني تقليدي
موجود منذ مئات
السنين في جميع الأوبرا الصينية الأخرى ،
إنها الأوبرا الوحيدة التي تستخدم صندوق الصوت
وقوة الحجاب الحاجز لغناء
الأوبرا الأخرى التي تستخدمها  في الغالب ،
أرى أني أتيت من عائلة تشو تشو
وفي سن الثانية بالإضافة إلى جدتي
أحضرتني لتعليم عروضك ، بدأت
في الأداء في سن الثالثة ، أذهب
إلى البصل وأذهب إلى المدرسة الثانوية وأحيانًا
قد تكون جلسات التدريب بعد ذلك
لقد كانت حالات اضطررت
فيها للنوم في الساعة 2:00
صباحًا لأن لدي مدرسة ما
هو الطعام الذي يجب أن أقوم به لقد سافرت إلى
العديد من البلدان لحضور العروض التي
لم أكن أتوقع أن يصبح ذلك
ملحوظًا في مثل هذا  أ ش  خلال فترة زمنية قصيرة ،
كانت نيتي الأولية
أن أفعل شيئًا أحبه اليوم ،
تعتبر أوبرا تشو تشو بمثابة فن يحتضر ،
جمهورنا هو بشكل أساسي الجيل الأكبر
سنًا ، ولا يتم نقله إلى الأجيال الشابة.
تنجذب وتعود للأداء التالي ،
أريد أن تتذكر الأجيال القادمة
الجذور وترى شيئًا
جميلاً تمثالًا
[موسيقى]
أنت